Magnus will we see more from the  maskinson Twitch in the future the we  know you you have uh your own twitch  channel right  um and you've streamed from some of the  um the office Bill club and what are  your thoughts on on that  I have to say that your  um pronunciation is abysmal but uh apart  I knew you were gonna call me out for  that I'm sorry I'm I'm also reading in  real time go ahead  uh yeah I think uh muskanistan will be  uh we'll be back  um that's for um that's for sure for for  different uh different events so um  muskinerson has never been  has never been retired he's just been uh  been resting and he uh maybe he may be  coming back in the near near future or  at least in the medium future  Moscow descent Moscow Nissan yeah  okay all right